now
5 14 on your friday morning taking the
motivation ball and running with it i
mean that literally there's a proud mom
of two kids over at the macaw steam
academy in henderson she's fired up in a
good way
crystal dunning told me about the pe
teacher there isabel goldstein and the
before school activity she inherited
almost 20 years ago called desert
trackers crystal says kids crowd around
the school gate at 8 30 every morning so
they can get in and start running laps
until the bell rings for classes to
start
those laps are recorded on a card by
parent volunteers
with celebratory cowbell rings for every
kid who racks up 10 miles in laps
crystal says some kids walk and chat
with friends while others run their
little hearts out she says the kids are
not just learning about physical fitness
that she sees him learning that they can
do anything if they set their mind to it
[Music]
all right on any given morning you'll
see fifth graders walking hand in hand
with pre-k so don't get run over other
kids stopping to help classmates who
stumble and fall if you know something
that's cool at school let us know head
to 8newsnow.com you'll find cool at
school under the community tab or just
send us an email cool at school at
8newsnow.com
and to highlight ms goldstein's 20 years
one of the kids there likes to show off
his own dad's name on a back in the day
plaque over there where his dad was a
desert tracker 20 years ago that's so
cool
that's really neat it's amazing yeah
good stuff a lot of history got a lot of
generations here i think people don't
realize how many generations of nevadans
there are still here and teachers who
have the kid who was a kid now is
somebody's dad
yeah wow